he served in World War one and World War
two he's still one of Germany's most
respected military leaders and yet he
never even wanted to be in the military
who is this man that led German troops
to victories that define Hitler at his
own peril what made him who he is and
what keeps his name in the history books
well that's what we're looking at in
today's via graphics the life of our win
Rommel the desert fox
born in Germany in 1891 Oh in Rommel
didn't have the military in his DNA his
father was a teacher and he was the only
member of family to enter the military
as a career of his three siblings that
live to adulthood one brother became a
dentist another became an opera singer
and his sister became an art teacher as
a child Rommel wasn't particularly
athletic in fact he's even been
described as frail but he hit his stride
in his early teens discovering sports
and becoming a leader among his peers
around this same time he also discovered
his love of mathematics and engineering
he built his own glider and was known to
spend his free time taking apart
machinery and putting it back together
again a teenage Rommel even dismantled
an entire motorcycle and rebuilt it now
robot he was clearly intelligent that
his grades they didn't reflect it
without good grades Rommel couldn't
continue his education at university
with his talent for machinery he
considered working at a factory nares
childhood home but his father didn't
want him working that instead his father
pushed Rommel into military service at
the age of 18 Rommel began studying at
the officer cadet school in Tokyo as
part of the 124 for Wurttemberg Infantry
Regiment he graduated in 1911 by January
of 1912 was commissioned as a lieutenant
as a battery commander he became part of
the one hundred and twenty fourth
weingarten regiments so he showed his
military talent early on he was still a
young men and it's no surprise that
Rommel had more going on in his life
than just his military service Rommel
had met a young woman by the name of
wahlburger stemmer while he was posted
in Weingarten the team began a romance
and wahlburger ended up pregnant when
Rommel learns of her pregnancy he
promised that they would marry and live
in a house and be a family before they
could marry though while they gave birth
to a daughter that she named Gertrude
months later Rommel stationed away from
Weingarten sent wahlburger a letter that
contained far different news than what
she expected the letter broke the news
that he couldn't marry her she wasn't
from the right class to be an officer's
wife and Raul's career was his priority
then there was the fact that he was also
in love with another woman
the other woman was at Lucy Mullen she
and Rommel met while he was in cadet
school though they did not marry until
Rommels a clear commitment to Lucy did
not stop Wahlburgers from loving him
though
she stayed devoted to him for
years believing that as long as he never
had children with another woman there
was a chance that he would return to her
but he never did
in 1928 wahlburger learned that Lucy was
pregnant with Rommels trials unable to
deal with the news she killed herself
Rommel and Lucy were supportive of
Gertrude both financially and
emotionally they welcomed her into their
home they did introduce her as their
niece when Rommel was fighting in Africa
the scarf that he wore was knitted for
him by Gertrude Rommel and Lucy's own
son Manfred was born in 1928 and even
went on to become mayor of stewed art 20
years as Raul's family life was taking
shape so was his military career months
after his illegitimate daughter was born
World War one broke out Rommel began his
war service as a platoon commander in
Verdun where he soon established the
fearlessness that he became known for
only a month into the war he charged a
group of French soldiers with a bayonet
on his own he had no ammunition but the
French troops did rawat was shot in the
leg but this was only to be the first of
many injuries that he sustained during
his military service Rommel was so well
known for charging ahead and ending up
in the thick of it that his troops used
to say where Rommel is there as the
front row both served in France Romania
and Italy during World War one he was
not only respected for his courage but
for his leadership in implementing new
strategies and maneuvers for warfare one
of Rommels most exceptional victories
came as he led troops in the mountainous
region of Caporetto in Italy Rommels
troops were poorly fed conditions were
horrific but with the use of new
infiltration tactics the German and
austro-hungarian troops had a decisive
victory over the Italian army 9,000
Italian men were captured 150 of them
officers Rommel didn't achieve this by
following orders quite the contrary in
fact when he was told to stand down he
moved forward and attacked he also used
the strategy of coming out the attacks
from surprising directions and creating
confusion and disorder among the Italian
troops for his role in the battle Rommel
received the pole in their reach a
prestigious German Order of Merit even
before his achievements at the Battle of
Caporetto Rommel had earned the Iron
Cross and had been promoted to first
lieutenant in 1918 he received another
promotion to captain when World War one
ended Rommel stayed in the military
leaving the
Infantry Regiment insta got most of the
work involved dealing with civil unrest
but Rommel didn't use the same
aggressive tactics he was known for in
the battlefield in fact he avoided using
force as much as he could
negotiations took the place of action in
the town of lindau rather than attack
the Communists who were staging an
uprising in the town Rommel used
diplomacy to get the city's governments
back under control recognized for his
leadership capabilities Rommel was soon
appointed to teach at The Dresden
Infantry School among the advice Rommel
offered future military leaders is this
advice that he followed in his own
military career be an example to your
men in your duty and in your private
life never spare yourself and let the
troops see that you don't in your
endurance of fatigue and privation
always be tactful and well mannered and
teach your subordinates to do the same
avoid excessive sharpness or harshness
of voice which usually indicates the man
who has shortcomings of his own hide
during this time Rommel also said to
work putting his military strategies on
paper in 1934 Rommels book on infantry
training was published he was no longer
teaching having left that role in 1933
but he was leading troops in gauslaa it
was in gossip that he encountered Adolf
Hitler for the first time
Hitler was chancellor and he was in
Gosselaar to inspect troops by 1937
Hitler was well aware of Rommel and his
reputation he named Rommel the war
ministry liaison for the Hitler Youth
but Rommel was not a member of the Nazi
Party
ian's another Hitler Youth Leader
disagreed about tactics and organization
for the group and in the end Rommel lost
his role in 1938
even though Rommel wasn't a member of
the Nazi Party he was still a supporter
of Hitler during his rise to power he
did agree with Hitler's efforts to
remilitarization
Hitler still wanted Rommel in the upper
echelons of the military in fact he made
a direct request that Rommel be part of
the unit that traveled with Hitler the
assignment not only gave Rommel access
to the Fuehrer but it also gave him more
free time for his hobbies and interests
than he had ever had before he once
again started focusing on math and
engineering and even took time away to
go skiing but this wasn't a last because
war it was just around the corner
1939 was a watershed year for Europe and
the world under Hitler's orders Germany
invaded Poland on September the 1st 1939
as part of the preparation for the
invasion Rommel had been promoted to
Major General and was entrusted with
protecting Hitler as war erupted then in
1940 ronald was put in charge of the 7th
Panzer Division the Panzer divisions
made up of armored tanks were an ideal
opportunity for Rommel to put his
particular strategic skillset on display
initially plans were for Rommel to head
up a mountain division but with Hitler's
support Rommel was able to land at the
head of the division he wanted in
addition to armored tanks Rommel was
also leading rifle regiments a
motorcycle battalion and an engineer
battalion and he was doing this out of
the usual order of military protocol
when Hitler made ramallah General he
bypassed other more experienced military
men to do so this started some
grumblings within the German military
but Rommel soon proved himself to be
worthy of the rank
he put his division through their
training paces for months and in May
they set off for battle in France the
battle it didn't start out well for
Rommel and his troops bridges were out
where they needed to cross a river and
the French were firing stopping the
German troops from making attempts to
cross but what more outsmarted them he
said buildings on fire creating a wall
of smoke that gave his troops the cover
they needed as they fired back across
the river at the French they then got in
rubber boats and made their way across
the water using materials from another
Panzer Division they built a bridge and
the full division moved across Rommel he
wasn't standing back and giving orders
no the general was actually in the thick
of the action firing a machine gun and
even wading into the water to put the
bridge together once again
Rommels division made quick progress
within days they had captured 10,000
French soldiers and only lost three
dozen of their own men for this victory
Rommel was awarded the Knight's Cross in
the coming weeks Rommel continued his
advance across France he announced his
successes to Hitler in a telegram
containing only four words em on the
coast throughout the 7th Panzer
divisions move across France Rommel
moved his troops so quickly and
surreptitiously that even the German
High Command couldn't keep track of them
this led them to dub is the ghost
division after the Germans marched
through France
stories arose about Rommel shooting an
unarmed French prisoner for not
following orders
he's also been accused of involvement in
the massacre of French African soldiers
from Senegal and men under his command
were involved in the killing of dozens
of men who were surrendering and
therefore posed no threat to the German
soldiers while some of his troops were
very likely involved in such atrocities
historians believe Rommel would not have
given commands for such brutal attacks
according to historian Rafael Shak
although there is no evidence
incriminating Rommel and self his unit
did fight in areas where German
massacres of black French prisoners of
war were extremely common in June 1940
after the German takeover of France the
plan was at first for Rommel to head to
Britain that would be the next nation
that Germany would take over but it was
decided that the German air force wasn't
strong enough to do what needed to be
done in order to take over England and
instead Rommel was sent to Africa the
Afrika Korps was a newly created
division of the German military and
general Rommel was the man who led it to
victories the Italians had been
suffering crushing losses in northern
Africa and Hitler wanted the Germans
there to beat back for British Rommel
arrived in Libya in 1941 and he was
supposed to answer to the Italian
commanding military officer but he
disagreed with the Italians tactics they
wanted the Italian and German troops to
use a defensive strategy Rommel wanted
to advance and take on the British
directly Hitler agreed with Rommel meant
Rommel began planning an offensive the
British however had no idea that was the
plan their only intelligence was the
Rommels orders were to stay put when
Rommel moved his troops forward they
were caught well off-guard
Rommels sly maneuvering had proved
fruitful for him once again but even
with success the Italian leader
Garibaldi was not happy Rommel had
disobeyed orders and no matter the
outcome that was not the way the
military was supposed to work however
Rommel he had a response for Garibaldi
though one cannot forget unique
opportunities to sit by for the sake of
trifles outside of Germany Rommel was
capturing the attention of world leaders
Winston Churchill was known to utter
what else matters but beating him but
the nickname he earns miss clandestine
maneuverings in Africa is what has stuck
through the decades of history and I
would be the desert fox but his
successes they came to an end the
British recaptured the city of Tobruk
and Rommels gains had been
lost then Rommel was part of a crucial
meeting with Hitler and another german
military leader albert kesselring the
two field marshals they disagreed in how
the Germans should move forward in Italy
they presented their arguments and
Hitler agreed with Kesselring Kasserine
took over and Rommel was moved to lead
the troops on the coast of France by the
time Rommel was reassigned to France he
was starting to be more and more
skeptical of Hitler his strategies and
his goals Rommel didn't support the
brutal actions of the SS and eventually
he came to believe that a Germany would
be better off negotiating an end to the
war instead of continuing the carnage
and all the death and he wasn't alone in
his beliefs a group of men who agreed
with Rommel even suggested that he
should become Germany's new leader
though Rommel didn't act on that
suggestion
the mere fact he had the suggestion
ultimately helped seal
Rommels fate from the time he was in
charge of coastal forces in 1943 Rommel
spent his time and strategy building up
coastal defenses he set mines built
barbed wire obstructions and even had
troops flood areas of the coast to make
it harder for treats to pass through he
also wanted to bring more tanks closer
to the coast but no one else agreed with
him that that was necessary in the
summer of 1944 it would turn out that
Rommel well he was right to want to move
more tanks to the coast On June the 5th
1944 Rommel left France he headed home
to Germany so that he could be with his
wife on her birthday June the 6th when
he left France he and the rest of the
German military thought the weather
would be bad and they didn't have to
worry about any allied movement on the
coast and they also thought that if any
trouble was to come it would be a Calais
but the Allies had used the German
military's weak intelligence system to
get them to think that the attack would
come at Calais while he was at home
celebrating his wife's birthday Rommel
received a phone call that shocked him
the Allies had landed at Normandy on
June the 6th the weather had cleared and
the troops were storming the beaches
Rommel left Germany immediately to head
to the front he and other leaders
established a counter-attack plan but
allied fire was too strong and needed
troops weren't able to arrive Rommel
himself was injured badly by Allied
airstrikes in the end 155 thousand
Allied troops landed during the d-day
invasion growing to 1 million after the
initial push the forces stormed through
German defenses during the summer of
1944 sir Rommel it was clear that
Germany couldn't overcome the losses and
he continued forward march of the Allies
he broke the news of his assessment to
Hitler telling him that a political
solution was likely the best way forward
at this point the Fuhrer though he did
not agree this meeting would ultimately
be the last between the two men as
victory for Germany was looking less and
less likely opposition to Hitler was
growing in Germany high-ranking military
officials including those close to
rommel were starting to make plans to
get rid of Fuehrer assassination was
among the many options they contemplated
knowing Rommel disagreed with Hitler and
was growing increasingly upset with the
Fuhrer the men plotting to overthrow
Hitler tried to bring him into the fold
to this day it's unclear if Rommel was
actually involved in a plot to
assassinate Hitler or not and if he was
it's unclear just how much he knew his
widow later said Rommel only wanted
Hitler to be brought to court and
nothing more if you're a very he thought
that Rommel wanted him dead and in the
end that's what masses on July the 20th
1944 a group of conspirators smuggled a
bomb inside a briefcase into a meeting
at Hitler's headquarters there was
supposed to be two bombs but there was
only time to prepare one and when it
exploded Hitler survived instead of a
successful coup the conspirators found
themselves facing treason charges and
the death penalty and Rommel was among
those implicated
in October 1944 two of Hitler's generals
confronted Rommel as SS troops
surrounded the area
the generals told Rommel that he had
three options he could go to speak to
Hitler directly and explain himself he
could go to court or he could commit
suicide there and then Rommel well he
opted for suicide in his final
communication with his wife he explains
why in view of my services in Africa I
have the chance of dying by poison two
generals have brought it with them it is
fatal in three seconds if I take the
poison none of the usual steps will be
taken against my family that is against
you they will also leave my staff alone
having explained to his family what was
to happen Rommel got into an SS car he
took the cyanide capsule but Hitler's
general had brought and he died he was
wearing his Africa Corps jacket and
carrying his field marshals baton the
world was told he died of wounds he had
sustained from Allied air attacks in the
wake of d-day and he was buried with
full military honors only after the war
did the truth emerge Rommel was not met
with the same disdain from world leaders
as other Germans were in the wake of
World War two even Winston Churchill
spoke highly of him he also deserves our
respect because although a loyal German
soldier he came to hate Hitler and all
his works and took part in the
conspiracy to rescue Germany by
displacing the maniac and tyrants for
this he paid the forfeit of his life
when Rommel was a talented leader but
his military duties served a regime that
had terrible intentions and committed
horrific atrocities
Rommels life and death were intertwined
with a watershed era in human history an
era upon which he left its mark so I
really hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below and do not
forget to subscribe we put out brand new
videos every Monday and every Thursday
also check out some videos from the
archive over there on the right also if
you want to vote on who we do on this
channel please head over to our website
and do so there is a link in the
description below and as always thank
you for watching